so the question is has the Democratic
Party changed irreversibly are we going
through a moment you know a frenzy that
will subside and the party will get back
to making economic arguments I mean put
some perspective on this if you would I
think we're going through a moment and I
do think the party will get back to the
party of my dad's kind of Democratic
Party my dad was a union construction
worker and he used to say if you care
about workers you have vote for the
Democrats and that's the Democratic
Party that I grew up in and I think
we'll get back there that's where I get
the sense most Democrats are but the
loudest voices in the room are getting a
lot of coverage right now and the
activists have had a very strong kind of
voice in the party and in many ways the
DNC has been enabling it this Democratic
primary so I the last point you're
making and I'm not a Democrat so I'm
from the outside looking in but it seems
to be right just from everything I'm
reading and hearing why would they do
that because clearly most voters are
closer to where you are than to where
some of these other candidates are so
what would be the point
you know you never know who's really
making the decisions behind the scenes I
mean they're they're requiring a certain
number of small dollar donations to
qualify for the debates yet we all know
that the people who tend to make small
dollar donations online tend to live in
New York in California and tend to
represent
the more extreme parts of the party I
mean half the American people can't
afford their basic necessities I'm
running to help those people they're not
making a lot of donations to Democratic
candidates online so I just think we've
got our priorities all wrong in terms of
how we're choosing who gets debate
issues on the debate stage in front of
the American people so in 1972 Democrats
really hated Richard Nixon and they
thought you know they attacking him
personally would work and they nominated
the most radical person they could find
and they lost and that lesson enabled
Bill Clinton to win two terms because he
looked at that and said you know that
doesn't work why halves have Democrats
forgotten that lesson
you know I've made that point I mean if
you look at Mondale and Dukakis they ran
very far to the left they turned off
independent voters they didn't run on
core economic issues kitchen table
issues pocketbook issues building
infrastructure creating jobs improving
people's wages but Bill Clinton actually
barack obama people forget about barack
obama he was the more moderate candidate
in a 2008 primary compared to john
edwards and hillary clinton so that's
the lesson we've got to remind ourselves
I mean obviously there's a lot of rage
for the current president but if we want
to beat him we have to capture
independence and the way to capture
independence is by running on things
that a majority of the American people
support it's actually pretty simple and
what most people care about is you know
their kids education their job their
health care their pay you know
opportunities for their kids those basic
issues that affect every American we
have to get back to that as a party yeah
I mean what you're saying is I mean you
and you could substitute Republican for
Democrat I mean it's it you know yeah
that's the substance that's the core of
politics right there right they care
about their job and their pay they care
about their kids public education they
care about their health care and they
want to know that the next generation
their kids and grandkids are going to
have opportunities then they want to be
safe that's what most Americans care
about I know it's not hard it's so weird
it's so weird that you're one of the
only guys saying that but anyway I'm
glad you are thanks so much for joining
us safe juggling thanks Ralphie Tucker